There is something really interesting going
on in the still early stages of the 2020 general
election.
Now I'm saying general election because the
Democratic primary, I guess we can say is
well underway now.
Debates start in just a couple of weeks, but
on the general election side, Donald Trump
is only now starting to even really campaign
in earnest.
You might remember that he filed for reelection,
I think it was on inauguration day in 2017
or soon thereafter, or right before, right
around inauguration day 2017.
Trump was technically speaking, running for
reelection in 2020.
But he's not really fully started his campaign.
And it turns out the Trump campaign in the
last several weeks has taken some internal
polls of key battleground states and Donald
Trump is losing badly in some of those.
And we've now learned thanks to a really good
New York Times report that Donald Trump has
been going out of his way to demand that his
staffers and his administration suppress the,
uh, negative internal polls that they have
taken.
For example, internal polls in Michigan and
Pennsylvania show that Donald Trump is currently
losing badly against any of the hypothetical
Democratic presidential nominees.
Important to understand, these are internal
campaign polls.
They're not public polls.
There are polls that the campaign takes for
their own purposes.
Trump's campaign went and did polling in 17
states, and when Donald Trump was presented
with the information, he said, no, no, no.
Say that we're doing well and bury this data.
We don't want this stuff getting out.
Now, unfortunately, even without the incipient
leaks from the Trump administration, other
pollsters have also been polling in many of
these states, and that information is now
public morning consult, for example, found
that registered voters in a bunch of states
are really negative on Donald Trump.
Only 39% of New Hampshire voters approve of
Trump.
Only 42% of Wisconsin voters approve of Trump.
Trump has a minus 13 unfavorability versus
favoribility rating.
Remember, Trump won Wisconsin narrowly in
2016, Michigan, which Trump won in 2016 he's
minus 12 in terms of approval, Iowa, which
Trump won in 2016 he's minus 12 unfavorability,
Pennsylvania minus seven.
He won that in 2016, Arizona Trump is now
minus six, which he won in 2016, Ohio and
North Carolina, Trump won both.
He's minus four right now.
And even if you look incredibly at some solidly
red states that Trump won in 2016, it's shaky
in Georgia.
Trump is only plus one.
Uh, in North Dakota and Kansas.
Uh, Trump has only plus one Texas and Indiana.
Trump is only plus three in net favor ability.
Now I, before I go any further, this tells
us nothing about how 2020 will go.
Okay.
This doesn't mean no matter where you vote,
that you don't have to worry about voting
for someone other than Donald Trump.
But these numbers combined with Trump panicking
and trying to suppress news of these PR of
this polling does tell us that number one,
Trump is at least somewhat worried.
Uh, number two, Trump knows that to some degree
things are not looking great in some of these
key states.
And number three, this tells us Trump can
easily be removed in 2020 if voter turnout
is what it should be, what could be what we
want it to be.
In one sense though, I think it's good that
Donald Trump is reacting this way to negative
polls.
If Trump's side negative Paul's and said,
I need to turn on my campaign game 100%, um,
that's actually something he could do to turn
these numbers around.
If Trump sees these numbers and says, let's
suppress them rather than let me campaign
really hard.
Hopefully he just hangs out, plays golf, watches
Fox News, ignores the polling, ignores the
dissatisfaction from the country tweets nonsense,
and that'll help them be defeated.
But as Trump's opposition, it's really important
that we not be in any way satisfied just by
seeing this data into thinking that this is
going to be an easy one in 2020 by any means
in every state, every voter should be behaving
as if your vote could be the vote that hands
your state, either to Donald Trump or to somebody
else.
By virtue of whether you choose to vote or
choose to stay home, we don't know which states
are going to ultimately make the difference.
It could once again be places like Michigan
and Wisconsin.
It could be somewhere else.
The polling is interesting.
Trump's internal team finding that he's losing
bigly in some of these states is fascinating,
but none of it should be used as a reason
to do anything other than vote in the primary
vote in November of 2020 period.
Let me know what you think about this latest
state polling in key battleground states.
I'm on Twitter at [inaudible]
the pacman.
Please follow me there.
Follow the David Pakman show on Twitter as
well at
David Pakman show,